ladies and gentlemen please welcome
studio director of in software Tim
Willits
good evening and welcome to the Bethesda
III showcase yes quake is back the game
that define competitive multiplayer is
back and better than ever you know it's
it's hard to believe that 20 years ago
quake was first released and you know if
you'll excuse the pun the aftershocks
can still be felt to this day quake set
new standards for multiplayer and push
the boundaries for graphics and gameplay
quake also became a pioneer for eSports
and twenty years later quake is still
played in tournaments across the globe
the biggest of those tournaments is our
very own annual gathering quake on which
will attract this August tens of
thousands of people to Dallas as a co
designer of the original game I am
extremely proud and excited to be
standing here today to announce the next
chapter of this great game quake
champions
quake champions is a competitive arena
style first-person shooter for the PC
designed for players of all skill levels
whether you are new to quake or have
been fragging for the last 20 years
quake champions will give you the
challenge and rush you'd expect from its
software multiplayer games now we know
that high-end performance is critical
with this type of game you know so be
assured as with any it software game
that quake champions will be fast with
amazing graphics running at a hundred
and twenty Hertz with unlocked frame
rates yes you're gonna get
heart-stopping action that will keep you
on the edge of your seat as you fight in
classic arena combat quake champions
also taps into another hallmark of the
franchise unique and badass characters
the game features a diverse cast of
warriors each with different attributes
and unique abilities allowing you to
fight the way that you want and you know
that it has a long tradition of
supporting competitive tournaments and
that continues with quake champions the
game is designed for world-class eSports
play at every level from the world's
greatest quake players to anyone willing
to test their skills in the arena so as
part of the launch plan for quake
champions Bethesda will be supporting
and expanding competitive tournaments
and leagues beyond quake gun and we'll
have more to share about that in the
coming months I hope you enjoyed the
sneak peek into our newest game join us
at quakecon in august and we'll have
even more to talk about and now please
join me in welcoming Bethesda's global
breast vice president of PR and
marketing piet hein